con unos minutos de retraso el magnate y
fundador de amazon jeff bezos ha
emprendido su viaje al espacio a bordo
del 'news y para de la compañía blue
origin que él mismo creó en el año 2000
para hacer viajes comerciales fuera de
la tierra pero no lo ha hecho solo su
hermano marc lo ha acompañado también
walt y fan que con 82 años es la mujer
de mayor edad en ir al espacio y con
oliver down un chico de 18 años que se
ha convertido en el tripulante espacial
más joven de toda la historia en total
han sido unos 11 minutos a una velocidad
de 3 mil 700 kilómetros por hora
triplicando a la velocidad del sonido
hasta llegar a unos 100 kilómetros de
altura lo que se considera que ya es
espacio exterior y allí han podido vivir
la sensación de ingravidez durante unos
momentos una fugaz experiencia al
alcance de muy pocos ya que cada
trayecto a la estratosfera cuesta 28
millones de dólares con este viaje de
eso se suma a la carrera del turismo
espacial algo que sólo dominan unos
cuantos hace nueve días el magnate y
filántropo richard branson hacía lo
propio desde el aeropuerto espacial
space port en el desierto de nuevo
méxico con su compañía virgin
el británico ha insistido en varias
ocasiones en que esto no se trata de una
competición sino de una manera de
contribuir al sector aerospacial